we begin with a historic decision for
Sweden and Finland to have announced
their intention to apply to join NATO
hoping the Western military Alliance
will bolster their security following
Russia's invasion of Ukraine already
NATO Partners their accession looked
like a done deal but NATO member turkey
now says it will not approve the bids
president erdogan repeated his
accusation that Sweden and Finland are
harboring members of groups at Ankara
deems terrorists Moscow has described
Sweden and finland's moves as a mistake
warning that it would be forced to
restore military balance including the
use of nuclear weapons
it's really succession to data would end
two centuries of Swedish military
neutrality prime minister Magdalena
Anderson underscored the significance of
this change in her country's security
policy
it is a historical and considerable
shift for our country we are leaving one
era and beginning another
but we can enter this new era with
confidence because we are doing it with
the best of our history Studio
the invasion of Ukraine shows what
Russia is prepared to do and we must
consider the possibility of Russia
acting with the same risk-taking in our
immediate neighborhood
threatening statements have been made
against us from the Russian side Sweden
categorically rejects these threats our
security policy is a matter for Sweden
and no one else
and a strong Nordic voice in NATO gives
us increased opportunities to protect
our common interests in the Baltic Sea
region
the best thing for the security of
Sweden and the security of the Swedish
people is to join NATO and do it
together with Finland
well finland's Minister for European
Affairs tuti topper Reiner and explained
to DW why her country had decided to
apply for NATO membership now
well February 24th changed everything
for us it was the wake-up call not just
for our spins but to us all to assess
the changing security environment and
let us be clear that Finland has not
been neutral in any sense we have been
firmly rooted in the western square of
the world we have been member in the
European unions in since 1995. so in
that sense it was quite natural for our
public to react to this war in a way
that the support for NATO membership was
uh huge already from the first balls
polls uh in in in early March so none of
us is surprised that kremel is not in
favor of NATO enlargement it has
expressed this this may uh for you for
Finland and Sweden joining NATO already
for many years so that is nothing new
and they also said that they will have
to do some kind of balancing measures if
with should join Nate so but we will not
let Russia intimidate us Russia cannot
dictate our own National decisions and
on the other hand it can also be
possible that Russell simply States the
obvious that Finland has already been so
close to Nato we have enhanced
opportunities partnership with NATO so
we are already so close as one can be
without being actual members so it can
be possible that process simply uh
adapts to this new reality
let's look at this new reality with
Elizabeth broad she's a senior fellow at
the American Enterprise Institute Think
Tank she joins us from Washington or
welcome to DW so we have Sweden and
Finland speaking about feeling
vulnerable following uh Russia's
invasion of Ukraine what is Their Fear
what Russian action are they hoping to
ensure themselves against by joining
NATO
uh I don't think they would specify any
particular fear for for
um for auto concern that Russia May then
do it precisely that but but it is the
the generally deteriorating security
environment in in the region
and we should remember that that Russia
is active in many areas a military areas
uh and uh areas below the threshold of
armed violence what is usually called
Gray Zone aggression so all of that
creates a a an environment where
um Russia can use really any Tool uh
that he comes up with uh to harm Finland
or Sweden or any other country and they
are very have been very good at
defending themselves but with such an
all-encompassing threat they have wisely
decided that it's better to be inside
the alliance with which they are already
cooperating very closely without getting
the benefit of any security guarantees
right and and so um uh at Sweden and
Finland say all right we're going to
apply to join NATO and all the NATO
countries except turkey say yay
um would Ukraine have cause to feel hard
done by because if this happens NATO has
refused to protect Ukraine because
Ukraine's not a member even though they
want to be and now Sweden and Finley
Island are asking for protection while
their application is is being considered
well it is it is a bit ironic is it not
that you
is stuck in this war
allegedly because he wanted to join NATO
that was Russia's uh really Russia's
motivated stated motivation for for
invading Ukraine or wanting to to
dictate its fate whereas Sweden and
Finland uh are at peace and are are not
being evaded at the moment by by Russia
and we're not even planning to join NATO
and now all of a sudden they are they're
walking into an open door because apart
from Turkey no country it seems uh seems
likely to voice any objection and they
are incredibly uh incredibly attractive
candidates which is of course the
difference between them and Ukraine for
for uh reasons a fair and unfair they
they have uh all the sort of attributes
that NATO wants in a candidate or a
member whereas Ukraine
um
it really would have a hard time
um gaining membership even if even if
there were no war at the moment so it it
maybe it's unfair maybe it's not but but
it is ironic at the very least right
we'll come to turkey's objections in
just a moment but first I'd like you to
help us understand Russia's reaction on
the one hand we have the deputy foreign
minister Sergey uh rayapkov uh quoted as
saying that Sweden and Finland they
should have no illusions that we will
simply put up with it and nor should
Brussels Washington and other NATO
capitals so he's there saying this is
gone too far now let's hear from the
Russian president
as for the NATO expansion including
through the new members of The Alliance
Finland and Sweden I would like to
inform you that Russia has no problem
with these states
and therefore the expansion at the
expense of these countries does not
create a direct threat to us Russia but
the expansion of military infrastructure
over that territory will obviously call
for our response
yeah and we will determine what that
response is based on the threats created
so Elizabeth bro we have a Russian
foreign minister promising the the fires
of hell and Vladimir Putin apparently
sitting there going meh
that's right and and before Sweden and
Finland made these announcements there
were various menacing statements from
Russian officials but the reality is as
your Finnish Minister who was just
quoted said Russia has been in no doubt
about where finland's loyalties lie
where Sweden's lawyers lie they have
been essentially cohabiting with NATO
for a number of years now Russia didn't
think it was that these were some single
countries out there up for grabs who
might join Russia in some sort of
Alliance they have been so integrating
so closely with NATO that it's just
um a matter of practicality to step
inside the tendon and get that
protection so uh Vladimir Putin who may
be irrational in other ways clearly
recognizes that and also by stating that
this is not an existential threat he's
essentially saying there won't be a
nuclear response from Russia which is
what so many observers had been worrying
about and and and the the threat that
there is lower level officials had been
voicing but if the president of Russia
says this is not an existential threat
clearly that is the last word from
Russia on whether it is an existential
threat okay let's talk about turkey then
threatening to hold up proceedings for
Sweden and Finland because President
erdogan says uh he accuses them of
harboring terrorists so do we believe
ankara's objections are genuine or is
President heard about looking to make
some sort of deal what does he want
president erdogan wouldn't be president
erdogan if fee didn't try to get
something out of any given situation
he's an extremely skilled tactician so I
think that's what's happening here he
sees an opportunity where he has
leverage meaning he his government has
to ratify the exception of these two
countries otherwise they won't be
joining NATO so he can get something out
of it I don't think there's in doubt
that at the end of the day uh turkey
will uh will approve will ratify their
accession but president one clearly
spots enough support an opportunity to
get something out of it and so he may
make various demands on on NATO on NATO
member states and Sweden Finland and for
example he may demand that turkey
finally gets us at 35s has been wanting
to get that something that has been
blocked by the U.S government there is
uh however a Twist in Sweden which is
that the current government is extremely
weak and Depends uh on uh one
parliamentarian who is an independent to
get its legislation through Parma and
she has very strong feelings about about
the Kurds and is now saying well in
Sweden is the Swedish government is is
being soft uh on Turkey so we'll see
where that leads but without her vote
the government won't be able to will
struggle mightily to get legislation
through Parliament uh but of course uh
it's uh it has taken on one side this
lone parliamentarian on the other side
we'll see where that goes good talking
to you thank you so much for for joining
us and explaining that to us Elizabeth
brore from the American Enterprise
Institute in Washington